are you going to stay in the race leader
McCarthy I'm not going anywhere
no it's a battle for the gavel on
Capitol Hill Kevin McCarthy losing the
first second and third vote to secure
house Speaker after 20 Republicans voted
against them but Kevin McCarthy's not
down for the count some members are
expecting this thing to go all night and
McCarthy's still confident he's going to
be speaker eventually keep this in mind
until Republicans can agree on a speaker
the house is basically Frozen meaning
they can't even swear in new members or
investigate Biden like they promised
Judge Jeanine yes
not a good look for Republicans today no
the ordinary American is sitting home
and saying what the heck is wrong with
these people we elected them we worked
hard we gave them money we now have the
majority in the house and they can't get
along with each other they don't they
don't like have enough problems with the
Democrats that they at least can't align
against the Democrats here's the issue
the issue right now is this we've had
three ballots so far 19 people in the
freedom caucus don't want a McCarthy
they just don't want to well stop having
one ballot after another you've got to
get together sit down I feel like Harold
Ford get together sit down and find out
what can we do to you 19 people to get
you in our group because right now I
don't want to hear about Hakeem Jeffries
I don't want to hear about the fact that
maybe some moderate Republicans will
align with moderate Democrats and
putting him Jeffries in now Chip Roy has
a point he's sick of the swamp we're all
sick of the swamp but he can't blame
McCarthy for the 1.7 trillion dollar
Omnibus Bill okay he can blame McConnell
because at the time McCarthy was not in
the majority okay could they have gotten
a continuing resolution yet and pumped
it over to January but they didn't do
that the truth is it's my last Point
McCarthy worked like a dog for the last
two years he raised 250 million dollars
for candidates some of whom haven't even
been sworn in yet and are against him I
mean this guy has done everything he
could whether you like him or you don't
like him you know it's time to get
together as a party and stop
embarrassing yourselves in front of the
rest of us how long can this last Dana
well a hundred years ago they went to
113 ballots oh God so this was the third
okay it could be a long night folks just
kidding it could be days I don't know
what's going to happen I think that
because he's not able to gain any votes
on the second third maybe even in the
fourth ballot at this point then you
have to say he's already given away way
a ton of things to these the small group
of holdout it's like the opposite of the
squad they make the squad look
positively reasonable uh in in this
situation and there a lot of this is
just an ideological thing it might be a
personal thing like I don't like you
okay okay well you know remember when
Nancy Pelosi she held open the vote you
had to there was no proxy voting for
speaker there was no proxy voted for
speaker because her numbers were very
very small but they were able to pull
together oh you're saying this is all a
secret ballot no no but last year
remember during covid how she allowed
people to vote from home oh right right
you couldn't do that for the speaker
vote because she needed to have every
single Democrat in the chamber so that
she could become a speaker yes she is
and yeah she was pretty good about
twisting those arms um I think that
conservatives overall in the country
remain deeply dissatisfied with Joe
Biden and every day that the Republicans
are going to spend in this exercise with
their heels digging in with the name
calling started to ratchet up and
they're talking about now internally in
within the party enemies you know that
kind of thing is hard to forget and one
of the first things that this group is
going to have to do is come together and
decide whether to raise the debt ceiling
so you thought like this ballot is a is
a tough one wait till you get to that
one we're just getting started with this
kind of drama Greg yeah you know
speaking of drama you know the
difference between that last vote 100
years ago and this one this one's on TV
what are we doing this is what is cause
if this was relegated to C-SPAN we
wouldn't even know it existed right and
and they would probably get through it
but because it's on like our shows now
they're like going across okay this is
this is for my future I'm gonna be like
I need to do this and make the people on
Twitter happy or the people or my
buddies in on television you know invite
me more often because you know I'm seen
as feisty giving it to the man but if it
wasn't on this we would know I brought
us this is why is that I was gonna ask I
want to fast forward through it when
it's up there I want to fast forward
because we know what the ending's going
to be right Danny is probably going to
be McCarthy but I don't care you don't
care I don't care this is the worst
first game of chicken ever it's like it
used to gave a chicken you have a car
going out the other and you wait this is
not even that it's not even that it's
just bad it's like it's like the
Republicans read a book by the Democrats
saying how to really screw up your party
you must really just love watching this
stuff
it's not a bad day to be a Democrat
dem's an array please headlines
everywhere
um
so I won't the judge doesn't want to
hear about a a candidate like a Fred
Upton or someone who could unify get
Democrats to come over and work with
moderate Republicans
well you said I don't want to hear about
any moderate Republicans so that's
really important to explain this to
everybody how that would work you're
saying you could get a moderate
Republican yeah to get enough Democrat
votes for speakers they will
for now we're in line right so 212 we
vote for Hakeem Jeffries if there is
somebody that is preferable to having
Kevin to Kevin McCarthy then you will be
able to pick off Democrats to do that
Hakeem Jeffries may vote for him himself
if it was someone like a Fred Upton
who's always been a moderate work with
Democrats voted to impeach president
Trump maybe they taught in Lee zeldin
who would not get Democratic who votes
for their own executioner because Trump
isn't around no I'm talking about
Republicans oh
[Laughter]
we've known for several weeks that this
group was going to vote against Kevin
McCarthy right they were the never
McCarthy folks but they never put
forward who their alternative was right
like who so who is who is your brother
and even you had somebody like a lot of
the Trump folks including the president
himself weighed in with these people who
don't want to vote from McCarthy and
said you guys what are you doing this is
you're crazy and they they all they
wouldn't listen to him either so I I
actually I really don't know how it ends
but they're not actually one faction
it's not just Freedom caucus folks so
you have like the Lauren boberts and the
Marjorie martial green is on McCarthy
side now Matt Gates and then you have
traditional Freedom caucus guys and
that's what you have three options you
have bags you have people I mean Jim
Jordan is up there nominating Kevin
McCarthy and then people are still
voting for Jim Jordan they don't they
want Anarchy they want to humiliate him
he has been completely humiliated and
that will continue probably for days
um and again dem's an array print it
just fast foreign
kill Mead I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now